pesco what was the most difficult scene
and on the horizon that for you as a
filming shoot I would say and that's the
thing it was not difficult because it
was the the garage scene with the
mechanic Mike the car scene because we
had to place the the beautiful cars we
had to wait for them it was just
timewise the most difficult challenge
because there's no scene it was super
hard to do seriously
maybe the thunderstorm with the white
desert it was a little bit difficult
because we were stressed about the time
but time was the biggest challenge for
the whole friend from A to Z if now with
more money a little bit I would have
done because the whole thing was
shutting 23 days and I would have taken
maybe 30 just to really take the time to
do the perfectly for example this thing
with Mike the mechanic in the garage we
finished around 7 a.m. and we were just
tired and I was just like we don't have
time for that Inc we don't have time
because we were waiting for cars to
arrive a luxurious car to be to fill up
the scene and that took so much time I
had problem with a camera I promise so
just timewise
he's just the that makes everything so
hard and difficult because I know if I
have a little bit more something will
bit maybe a little bit better but again
you know some time if I would have done
that say the white there's just seen a
net as a big one one take for five
minutes
I think it would have never been as
great so some time again everything
happens for a reason
and I love that but now knowing that
time is time is a so the mechanic
seen how long were you slated to be at
that location and then how long did it
actually take we started around 7:00
a.m. 7:00 p.m. and then we finished
around like like 7:00 a.m. and I was
supposed to be out around 2 a.m.
something like that oh wow yes it was
just thing didn't work out and I was
freaking out at one point I was just
calling my friend I was just like I'm
freaking out I'm freaking out totally
because it doesn't work and so I had to
make it work because like people are
waiting and that's they're all in the
whole thing that's the only moment I
freaked out because I can really see
that time was kind of pushing me to do
something that was not great and and
sometime you know the actor was not
delivering the right line forgot their
lines and
it was just everything because that's a
thing we had one day for death location
in the beautiful garage with the cars so
everything we had to two days of it
would have take two days to do
everything so yeah time was there
anything you could have done differently
or that was out of your control in some
sense because the cars didn't arrive and
you needed them for that scene yeah at
this point there's nothing I was just
waiting for this and then I was trying
to go as fast as I can but sometimes
it's just we lost at least a good three
four hours before shooting because we're
worrying for so many elements to arrive
and then at one point it was starting to
rain
and you can seem different there's one
scene you can see the lighting behind it
was a beautiful shot because now it
added to the film there's a beautiful
kissing scene and as you can see
lighting in the background but again
everything happens for a reason but now
knowing better will be that we need more
time if you can another one advice I
would say is that don't load your days
with so many things because that was at
least a two three days shoot and we put
that everything in one night so that's
why I was like yeah it's way way way too
much otherwise the rest was always good
eight hours ten-hour days everything was
smoothly yeah you have to deal with
weird weather and stuff like that but
otherwise that was the only big scene
that was we're missing time in France it
was beautiful we didn't have any trouble
you have to deal with rain sometime it
was a head again
you know in the for whatever the ending
of the film there's some rain and it
worked perfectly with the contrast of
something happening at the same time so
again everything happens for a reason
any advice for a filmmaker who's not
going to make their day and they either
have to call the location or if there's
a location manager they're asked to have
it extended what what would you advise
is someone else going through something
like that I can try to extend it maybe
one hour something if they are really
patient but it's it's important to not
overload your schedule or day because
that's if you start because the third
thing for example the castle we had it
for so many days if it was like hey we
need one more days no you know there
people are coming or it's booking and it
costs like thousands of
so it's like he it sucks but if you miss
times then you reshoot something else
you find a way or you eat it around it
but you yeah if you if that was one of
the scariest thing I just cannot do I am
I gonna miss something am I gonna lose
scenes but no everything I was super
lucky maybe some are not perfect like I
wanted but at least I got them all but
then in the editing there's always ways
to to work around it
you